in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading, from the Srinaksadion, for June 2, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Nikepharos, the confessor, archbishop of Constantinople.
On the second of the month we celebrate the memory of our Holy Father Nikepharos, the
confessor, patriarch of Constantinople.
Our Holy Father Nikepharos was born in Constantinople in about 758, during the persecution of the
veneration of the Holy Images by Constantin Copronimos.
His father, Theodore, was first secretary of the palace, Proto-Secretis.
As he valiantly professed his devotion to orthodoxy, he was dismissed from his office and sent
into exile in Nicaea, where he ended his days becoming for every one a true example
of piety.
The saint's mother, El Dhasia, wishing to cultivate the worthy dispositions of her son, confided
him to one of the emperor's secretaries as a pupil and retired to a monastery.
Nikepharos, having successfully completed all of the phases of secular studies, became in
his turn first secretary to the young emperor, Constantine VI, and Regent Irene, and he
took an active part in the 7th Ecumenical Council at Nicaea in 787 as imperial representative.
When orthodoxy was provisionally re-established, Nikepharos, regarding worldly glory and
honors, as of little worth, decided to respond to an inner call that urged him to embrace
the monastic life.
He retired to the furthest shores of the Bosphorus on the Asiatic coast to the district named
Agathu, where he founded a monastery.
Remaining a layman, he gave himself with zeal night and day to prayer and study, and acquired
not only a deep knowledge of the word of God, but also a better understanding of how to use
the philosophy and rhetoric that he had mastered with consummate art in God's service.
Far from becoming an occasion of pride, his knowledge of the secular sciences became for
him an opportunity to give thanks to God and to throw in the evangelical virtues.
A brilliant aristocrat and esteemed scholar, he showed himself free from all worldly attachment,
gentle, moderate, charitable towards all, and incapable of acting through love of vain
show.
When St. Tarasius was at the point of death in 805, he nominated Nikepharos as his successor,
a nomination unanimously accepted, and Nikepharos was elevated patriarch of Constantinople, in spite
of his own resistance and the fact that he was still a layman.
Emperor Nikepharos I at first opposed this election, but he then became its fervent promoter
and used all his authority to make the saint leave his solitude.
After being transferred among Nikepharos received successively in a few days all the degrees
of priestly orders, finally being consecrated patriarch on Easter day in the year 806.
At the end of the ceremony, the prellet solemnly placed on the altar a book he had composed
in defense of the holy icons.
This exceptional elevation of a layman to the summit of the ecclesiastical hierarchy provoked
the opposition of the monks of the studio monastery led by St. Plato and St. Theodore.
The tension only grew when the new patriarch decided to reinstate the priest Joseph, whom
St. Tarasios had deposed for having celebrated the unlawful marriage of Constantin VI into
the ranks of the priesthood.
The monks broke communion with the patriarch.
The emperor took the rigorous measure of exiling them, and Nikepharos could do nothing.
This tension only subsided with the accession of Michael I in 811, on receiving the crown
from the patriarch, the emperor committed himself to the defense of orthodoxy and recalled
the exiles, and in order to put an end to all dissension, Nikepharos agreed to depose
Joseph once more.
A firm defender of the veneration of the holy icons, the holy hierarchy, strove during
this lull to rid the church through his words and his writings of all influence of other
heresies.
He strengthened the holy institution of marriage by forbidding nobles to repudiate their wives,
and tried to correct certain abuses that had appeared in the monasteries by suppressing
double monasteries.
He had canonical discipline enforced in the whole church as an instrument of grace and
harmony.
This favorable situation lasted only for a short time.
Emperor Michael, unhappy with his war against the Bulgarians, renounced the throne and was
clothed in the monastic habit, being succeeded by Leo the Armenian in 813.
As soon as he entered Constantinople, Saint Nikepharos suggested to him that he signed a
profession of the Orthodox faith, with a promise not to make innovations in matters of faith,
but Leo declared that he would refuse to sign anything until his coronation.
During the coronation's ceremony, at the very moment when Nikepharos placed the crown
on the sovereign's head, he suddenly experienced a great pain, as though he had put his hand
into a thornbush or briars.
One day's later, when the patriarch again submitted the profession of faith to Leo, the
latter openly refused to ratify it, and a short time before Christmas in 814, promulgated
an iconoclast edict.
Saint Nikepharos then proclaimed a fast and assembled a great crowd in St. Sophia's
for a prayer vigil in which God was implored to turn away this new trial from the church.
The emperor, warned of this gathering and fearing the Saint's authority, summoned him
at dawn to the palace, and accused him of provoking public disorder.
Nikepharos defended himself from every charge of rebelling against the sovereign's authority,
but reproached the emperor for interfering inappropriately in the affairs of the church,
and of troubling its peace by introducing the venom of heresy.
A long theological discussion followed, in which Saint Nikepharos showed the solid
basis of veneration of the holy images.
He replied to the emperor that such veneration was not idolatrous, for, as God had made himself
visible through the incarnation of Christ, the representing of the humanity of our Lord
Jesus Christ, such as he appeared on earth, was to confess the reality of his incarnation,
and of our salvation.
The saint, having brilliantly refuted all the sovereign's arguments, Leo succeeded in
drawing a number of important bishops and clerics to his heretical cause, and these, along
with the iconoclast Theologians, came to Nikepharos after the feast of the Theophany and urged
him to submit.
The prelet responded by saying that, as all the churches had been of one mind about the
images since the Second Council of Nicaea, he could not enter into discussion with those
who had willingly excluded themselves from ecclesial communion.
He added that, should the emperor wish to continue to put pressure on him, he was ready to offer
his resignation.
As the discussion ended with no clear result, the saint deposed the clerics who had embraced
the cause of heresy, and, sensing that the hour of violent persecution was approaching,
wrote to the emperor's wife and to his ministers, asking them to use their influence with the
emperor so that no further blood might be shed.
At the beginning of the great fast when Nikepharos fell gravely ill, the emperor took from
him the control of the treasury of the great church, and gave it to one of his officials.
He then called together a panel of iconoclasts, before which he summoned Nikepharos, but
the patriarch gave an ardent defense of the true faith.
This was in vain, however, and the shepherds of the church, having become repacious wolves,
pronounced the saint's deposition.
On the 13th of March in the middle of the night accompanied by a menacing crowd that had
been assembled around the Patriarchate, the leader of the guard came to take him from
his bed of pain.
Having hardly the time to send up a last prayer in St. Sophia's confiding the care of his
church to the wisdom of God, he was thrust onto a ship and in turn in the monastery of Agatha,
where he had spent his first years as a monk.
A short time later, he was transferred to another more remote monastery, which he had
founded, dedicated to St. Theodore.
On his own initiative, Nikepharos then sent notice of his abdication to the emperor, who
placed Theodotus Casiteras, a sworn enemy of the holy icons on the patriarchal throne.
The latter quickly convoked an assembly of heretical bishops to give official confirmation to the
decisions of the Council of Yeria, 754.
The veneration of images was abolished, and the name of Tarasios and Nikepharos was unathematized,
and a new persecution against the confessors of the faith was let loose throughout the whole
empire.
This lamentable situation lasted until the assassination of Leo by Michael II and 820.
On seizing power, Michael, responding to Nikepharos's request, declared the decisions of
the iconoclast councils to be null and void, and called back Theodore the Studeit, and the
other confessors from exile.
But the law against the veneration of images remained in force, and it was still forbidden
in Constantinople.
Having been reconciled with the patriarch before the outbreak of persecution, St. Theodore
went several times to visit St. Nikepharos and wrote him letters of encouragement, in which
he praised him as the son of Orthodoxy, the beams of whose confession illumined the universe.
Michael II, to whom St. Nikepharos had written, exhorting him to restore Orthodoxy to
its fullness, offered to return the saint to his sea, if he promised to keep silence
about the holy icons in the council of Nicaea.
The holy hierarchy categorically refused, and preferred to remain in exile.
From this exile, he wrote important treatises, placing all the subtlety of Aristotle's philosophy
at the service of Orthodoxy, and showing that the icon of Christ does not reproduce the
unsircomescribable divine nature in an idolatrous and sacrilegious manner, as the iconoclast
of theologians maintained, but that there is in the icon a relation of likeness with
the person, Epostasis of Christ.
For the invisible God rendered himself visible through the incarnation, while remaining unsircomescribed
in his divinity.
He continued his glorious theological defense, until his death on the 2nd of June in 829.
After 14 years of exile, his body was buried in his monastery and remained there until
its translation to the Church of the Holy Apostles in Constantinople, a triumphal return that
signaled the definitive victory of Orthodoxy.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.